[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors monsieur attali on avait d'abord
un petit s micro si vous êtes d'accord
faut savoir s'il fonctionne ne
fonctionne pas il ne fonctionne pas
voilà très bien voilà alors votre
dernier livre s'intitule vivement après
demain le plus récent j'espère que c'est
le plus récent
j'espère que c'est pas le dernier c'est
pas le dernier ce ne sera pas le dernier
j'en suis sûr avant de parler d'après
demain
peut-on parler d'hier ma première
question est la suivante alors je suis
le relais des internautes à vous a posé
une série de questions il ya internet
comment notre passé influence-t-il notre
futur une influence tout simplement
parce que nous sommes ce que notre
histoire de la construit nous sommes ce
que nous sommes même biologique nos
raisons de notre évolution nous sommes
ce que nous sommes culturellement parce
que nos langues ont évolué nous sommes
ce que nous sommes en raison de la
culture que nous avons accumulé les
langues qui sont transformés en raison
de l'héritage que nous avons accumulés
et aussi en raison des catastrophes que
nous avons créée qui fait que l'humanité
aujourd'hui et dans un univers de plus
en plus fragile de plus en plus menacées
en raison de
ce dont nous avons hérité idéalement on
pourrait penser que le meilleur qu'on
pense le pire je pense que le meilleur
qu'on pense le pire je pense que nous
avons créé plus de choses positives que
nous n'avons de choses négatives en tout
cas les choses positives nous permettent
d'espérer avoir les moyens de compenser
des choses négatives
l'humanité a beaucoup plus de moyens de
faire le bien aujourd'hui qu'elle en
avait il ya ne serait-ce qu'un siècle
et puis peut-être surtout le plus
important de ce que nous avons héritée
du passé c'est notre capacité un peu
illusoire mais réelle a tiré des leçons
de ce qui nous est arrivé à utiliser nos
erreurs nos échecs nous faille naufrage
édité comme des moyens à prendre pour ne
pas les refaire
et donc le la pire chose que nous
puissions être c'est amnésique
c'est à dire ne pas vouloir voir le
passé et recommencer les mêmes erreurs
puisque nous sommes en train de faire
mille occasions en or fait des dettes
excessives
quand on détruit la nature quand on
accumule des armes de violence quand on
retourne au populisme quand on retourne
à la tolérance quand on retourne aux
guerres de religion tout ça on a déjà
connu et on sait très bien qu'elle va à
paris ça peut nous conduire donc les
leçons de l'histoire sur fondamentale
même si les hommes trouvent en général
qui les vivent mieux amnésique qu'avec
la mémoire alors la deuxième question
que l'on aimerait vous poser c'est
aujourd'hui nous avons l'impression que
tout va mal alors est-ce une réalité
notre monde va t'il si mal et même
souvent d'écrire une histoire l'humanité
en disant que c'est comme qui suit de
celle du temps mais avec les moyens de
faire plus de bien et puis je demande
plus de bien plus de mal mais de plus en
plus de biens de plus en plus de mal
voilà l'histoire de l'humanité et on est
peut-être en ce moment un moment on est
assez haut dans la post it faire du bien
est en train de basculer vers le mal
pourquoi assez ouvert la possibilité de
faire le bien
parce que
si on regarde les faits il ya un nombre
de faits positifs extraordinaire alors
lui parlant devant l'espérance de vie
qui n'a jamais été aussi élevé
qu'aujourd'hui le très loin il va
particulier l'espérance de vie des plus
pauvres qui a augmenté massivement et ce
nombre de vie en france continuent à
augmenter très rapidement
ensuite parce que la proportion jeunes
et bien la proportion de 90 des gens
très pauvres n'a jamais été aussi basse
alors il ya encore un milliard de gens
qui sont qui ont enfin tous les soirs
mais c'est plus bas que ceux moins de
dix portions de la planète aujourd'hui
que - dispensant de gens très pauvres et
moins de mes gars qui ça plus de 10% qui
sont en situation de famine
nous on se trouve dans une situation où
la pauvreté est en train de diminuer a
beaucoup diminué
étonnamment jusqu'il ya deux ans en tout
cas la violence n'avait jamais été aussi
basse que maintenant dans l'histoire
humaine
on a des statistiques assez ancien des
statistiques plus ou moins historique
mais qui montrent que l'avion s'est
énormément diminuer la violence
en pourcentage la population par an par
nombre absolu qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup
d'indicateurs qui montrent que ça va
beaucoup mieux ça va beaucoup mieux par
le passé mais toute façon et c'est
d'ailleurs une des raisons qui
expliquent le pessimisme spécifiquement
français on pourrait dire que en raison
d'un très grand nombre de choses qui
vont mal et qui semble aller de plus en
plus mal comme en particulier
l'environnement le climat les inégalités
et la concentration des richesses
le chômage en espagne a beaucoup de
choses dont on pourra parler tout à
l'heure il ya le sentiment que ça allait
bien et que ça ne peut aller plus mal et
d'une inflation c'est parce que ça va
très bien où relativement très bien que
ça peut l'être palais très mal donc
le pessimisme est liée à un constat
constatation de ce que les choses ne
sont pas si mal même si elles beaucoup
d'inégalités
donc ça va beaucoup mieux par le passé
avec une extraordinaire aggravation des
injustices et des inégalités et
énormément de nuages à l'horizon
très bien
alors maintenant magma question c'est
tout simple et elle rejoint celle des
internautes c'est que peut-on et doit-on
faire pour soi et pour les autres
d'abord il faut voir qu'il ya dans les
15 ans qui viennent très en nombre de
choses qui vont bien réglé et c'est il
faut placer ce qu'on peut faire pour soi
et pour les autres en fonction de ces
choses et énormément de choses qui vont
arriver qui sont à la fois des choses
qu'on peut regarder comme des
spectateurs mais dans lequel on vous
doit c'est votre question agir qu'est ce
qui va nous arriver dans 15 ans d'ici là
sont certainement 15 ans il y aura un
milliard d'habitants plus sur la planète
dans 600 millions en afrique 1 milliard
dont 600 millions de l'afrique est il y
aura au moins 50 millions de personnes
qui auront changé de continent
il y aura une espérance de vie qui sera
trois ans et demi plus élevé sur la
planète
yoran âge moyen de la planète qui sera
quatre ans plus élevé qu'aujourd'hui il
y aura un nombre de progrès techniques
incroyables qui vont se généraliser une
imprimante 3d
l'intelligence artificielle ou et
sémantique le biotechnologies les
nanotechnologies neurosciences n'est
d'abord allée du robot nombre de choses
un coin qui sont en apparence la science
fiction mais qui après demain sinon
demain sont des banalités de nos rues de
nos vies quotidiennes qui auront des
conséquences concrètes très passionnante
pour l'augmentation de l'espérance de
vie la fin de de le modifier
l'agriculture de façon très positive le
fait de répondre à des défis énormes par
exemple on sait qu'en raison de
l'évolution démographique et d'autres
raisons de pollution
la quantité d'eau disponible par
habitant de la planète va diminuer de
moitié en casant l'aqoci doté d'eau
disponible sur la planète va limiter de
moitié en 15 ans tout ça ça fait froid
dans le dos mais les progrès techniques
devraient permettre de les passer de
même il ya un autre facteur très
important c'est qu'aujourd'hui sur la
planète il ya 1 milliard 600 habitants
d'habitants qui sont dans la classe
moyenne c'est à dire qu'ils ont peu près
un niveau de vie décent relativement
leur niveau de vie l'environnement dans
15 ans commis narcisse va être trois
milliards sac énorme changement le
nombre de gens de clash mais surtout en
chine et en inde
parce que dans quinze ans la chine aura
moins d'habitants
le principal changement à apporter des
progrès formidables auxonne ali premier
technique laissant une classe moyenne
forte on a un sentiment d'une capacité
d'organisation d'une croissance de
l'humanité particulièrement de rentrer
mais en même temps les conséquences
négatives sont énormes
par exemple sap le fait que au moins je
dis bien au moins la moitié des métiers
existants aujourd'hui auront disparu
dans 15 ans au moins la moitié des
métiers existants aujourd'hui vont ils
pas leur talent sans parler des métiers
qu'on enseigne à l'école danse à 80% des
métiers qu'on enseigne à l'école
d'aujourd'hui car ont disparu parce
qu'ils sont en train d apprendre seront
en âge de les exercer
ce qui veut dire que il ya des mutations
formidable alors qu'est ce qu'on doit
faire
évidemment il faut faire plusieurs
choses il faut d'abord se rendre compte
qu'il ya des potentialités fantastique
ne pas être pessimiste résigné ce que
j'appelle résigné réclamant c'est-à-dire
résigné un papou a changé le monde se
prendre soi même en charge prendre
conscience d'un certain deux choses
fondamentales qui ne dépendent que de
soi et qui nous amène à agir ce que
j'appelle devenir soir c'est à dire
premièrement et vous en parler avec
frédéric saldmann tout à l'heure prendre
conscience de l'importance de sa propre
vie en conscience du fait qu'on est
mortel que notre vie est courte et qu'on
doit la vivre de la façon la plus
intense possible et la plus intense
possible ça veut dire la plus pleine la
plus respectueuse de soi la plus
respectueuse des autres la plus intense
en se donnant quelques principes de base
premièrement on n'a aucune raison de les
exercer un métier qui peut être exercée
par un autre entend faire quelque chose
de créatif parce que ça sert à rien ce
bref passage que nous avons sur cette
planète en faire quelque chose quelqu'un
nous peut faire autant pourtant ne rien
faire du tout deuxièmement ne pas se
contenter d'une seule vie pourquoi une
sellerie ont comme on n'est pas sûr
d'être un carnet essayé d'en avoir
plusieurs ne pas se limiter trouvé
profondément ce pourquoi en effet ils
partir d'un principe fondamental quand
on veut on peut
quand on veut on peut et quand on croit
qu'on peut pas c'est qu'on n'a pas
vraiment voulu
[Applaudissements]